all right today we're going to be
speaking with Mike Lindell Mike Lindell
will be a familiar face and name to many
in our audience CEO and inventor of my
pillow uh Mike I really appreciate the
opportunity to chat with you today
thanks for having me on of course so let
listen you first came to my attention I
first became aware of you at the start
of the pandemic Donald Trump held this
event at the White House and announced
here are some business people that are
going to be doing things to help us you
were going to be if I recall correctly
making masks and maybe even some other
things how did you first come to to meet
Donald Trump and that relationship start
well it was the summer of 2016. uh he
invited me to Trump Tower I was August
15
2016. it was a private meeting I went in
there it was about 35 minutes just him
and I and I walked out of there and I
didn't you know I didn't I come from a
past of addiction and stuff I didn't
think politics affected any but I did
walk out of his office said he's going
to be the greatest president ever if
he's if he's with all the things we
talked about we talked about you know my
pillow being made in the USA we talked
about I said I was going to have a a
platform which I do in the
lindellrecoverynetwork.org which helps
addicts and he said I'm going to stop
the drugs pouring in and we we just had
this back and forth and I went to my uh
went to his employees afterwards and I I
asked them I kind of did my due
diligence I'm going is this real I mean
the only agenda he had was to help our
country and and to help people and
that's what I and they all said yes he's
amazing boss amazing man and and they
all had a personal story about them and
then boy I got back to Minnesota and I
did a press release and you didn't think
I shot someone they attacked me and
called me a racist and called me
everything and all I did was say I had a
meeting with uh with Donald Trump that
was running for president you uh at that
event at the White House that I
mentioned at the start of the pandemic
you you said that Donald Trump was quote
chosen by God how how did God reveal to
you that that he had chosen Trump
well I was a bunch of divine
appointments for me I had a dream in the
spring of 2015 that I'd be meeting
Donald Trump and I'm going why would I
want to meet Donald Trump and all of a
sudden he comes down the escalator
running for president then ahead if you
in my book I explain all this I I
actually to the National Prayer
Breakfast in early
2016 and when Ben Carson was still
running for office and I was picked out
of 12 people out of the whole prayer
breakfast with thousands there to pray
to with Ben Carson in a room and um just
these things kept happening to me and it
was the building up and I'm going this
all has to mean something and uh it
wouldn't mean that I just end up going
golfing with Donald Trump or something
and uh like there was so many Divine
appointments that led up to that and
then uh I just uh it was something
different something that you know
because I had met him I just know this
had all these things that happened I
look at the tonight know that God exists
I use mathematics and say if you have a
one in a million happen or a one in a
billion or this thing or this thing
happens that could never happen when you
add them together and consider a miracle
and that's what kept happening to me and
I'm going I go this he's been picked
he's been chosen for such a time as this
wow so if I hear you correctly you're
saying what others might see as odds and
probability you see as Divine
appointment
especially when there's more than one
and then there's confirmations of that
wow you know here's a guy for me being
just an ex-addict from Minnesota a guy
very functioning at it grow you know
growing up again uh and here I end up in
the I end up in the white house I'll
tell you an example so I end up in the
white house uh at a round table event I
never thought it could come within a
hundred yards of the White House with my
past I see I see I see I see and here I
here I end up in the White House I said
who's sitting here and they go the
president is there's like 15 of us in
the room first time I was over the White
House and and uh they do that we go on
national TV then it's just him and I
facing forward and uh it went viral that
that screenshot and all my friends are
going what is this x crack addict
sitting next to the president United
States Jesus is real because this could
not happen this makes no sense right in
other words it's almost like
Mike Lindell pillow guy being at the
White House makes such little sense it
must be divine intervention absolutely
absolutely
it's just like when I spoke at the Rose
Garden there when we when I had went
there uh uh and we did start making
masks we had gotta I had got a uh a
letter from the White House saying would
you come in and uh because we had
started making mess we were one of the
first ones I believe in the country and
we get there and he's going to have us
all speak from the Rose Garden and you
have to have pre
pre-approved remarks and if I told you
the whole story I mean it's just uh it's
divine how everything went down he's
sitting in the front row right was
things that couldn't happen that was a a
series of events happened there where I
ended up being the only one on stage
with them and then asked him if I could
say something off the cuff and flip this
paper over and then spoke out about I
remember getting back in the word and
and it uh if you know if you think there
I mean I was that was hurt around the
world I did 109 interviews in seven in
five days well Mike listen there's so
many things I want to ask you about let
me do a few that are sort of like
shorter things one is
um in terms of states that were given to
Joe Biden that you believe Donald Trump
won what what is the how extensive is
that list it's huge and we and it's
absolutely huge and not that I believe I
know he won I because we have all the
packet captures and the data from the
whole election we'll get to that
Minnesota to New Hampshire
um
um all the swing States we talk about
Nevada
um Georgia Michigan Wisconsin
um Arizona Pennsylvania wow I mean it
the list goes on and on it's uh there
are very few that buy more less than ten
you at one point I heard you say you
believe Trump even won California do you
still believe that that that's that's
correct and we're going to reveal that
at the Cyber Symposium I'm happy and
these are going to be we actually will
have the data to back that up what's the
math of just to pick one Mike for people
to understand California has 22 million
registered voters 10 million are
Democrats and there's 5 million
Republicans how did Trump win California
I didn't say one for sure we're going to
reveal that this supposedly let's use
Minnesota okay uh my home state well
they are here they are losing Minnesota
by a hundred thousand votes now I went
around all over everyone say oh
Minneapolis and all we only had like two
big cities Duluth and Minneapolis St
Paul and it's all Democrats supposedly
right and all our Northern Minnesota
Democrats well that's that's the past
everybody that Democrat that ship sailed
those were traditional Democrats a lot
of them and Minnesota the actual number
Minnesota won Donald Trump won by 65
000. and we will show this too at this
Symposium yeah this is facts these are
facts and how did that happen because uh
it doesn't matter where you the the past
everything changed with Donald Trump
people people are voting I believe
people are voting for they want
politicians that are for the people that
think you know and Donald Trump did
stuff for all people if you get to our
great this great place we were in in
December of 2019 I think everyone
whether you're a Democrat or Republican
realizes that those those they that that
month that was a manifestation of a of a
couple years of decisions being made by
politicians I.E Donald Trump and that by
me and those Common Sense decisions that
made here's a problem here's a solution
how would help people all people not
just their party or a Personal Agenda
and that's what and we've seen that we
that was it was just awesome that
everyone in this country got to
experience that what what political
decisions could could manifest to and
man everything was great there we had
Kaya's consumer confidence lowest gas
prices lowest
um unemployed unemployment I mean the
list goes on and on yeah stock market I
mean across the board those were because
of political decisions everybody I I
want to focus in on the election piece
just so we we kind of keep to keep that
path forward there are some like
Marjorie Taylor Greene who while she
believes there were problems with the
election she says Trump is not coming
back he it is false hope to believe he
will be reinstated you've said August or
September do you still believe that in
what's the mechanism
a hundred percent I believe that yeah
she's just she's misconstrued I mean
they all these this is uh here's there's
a couple things here
um we're having the Cyber Symposium
after that that's August 10th 11th and
12th everybody's gonna watch this it's I
want it to be the biggest watched event
in history yep billion people you watch
that and you're gonna see the packet
captures and data from the whole
election this is non-subjective evidence
everybody it's what I've had for months
now and I've been trying to get the word
out but I keep let's just cancel Mike
Lindell and my pillow I've been trying
to get the word out now this gets out
we've had it ready for the Supreme Court
it's called a quot we bring that to the
Supreme Court and everyone says well
they're not going to bring back Donald
Trump yes they are here's why so hold on
Mike I wanna I wanna hear it but I want
to make sure the audience doesn't miss
it the Supreme Court is the mechanism
that will bring them back you're saying
there's there's more than one but I'm
giving you the first one okay okay it's
the easiest one okay okay the easiest
one this when we get through the Cyber
Symposium which everybody needs to tell
everybody to watch this is so important
because these nine Supreme Court
Justices they're people too they've
lived the American dream they have
families they have children
grandchildren friends family they need
to everyone everyone needs to watch this
because it shows that this was an attack
by China on our country it doesn't
matter if you're a Democrat or
Republican I sit on Jimmy Kimmel I said
Jimmy said if it was reverse Mike would
you do the same thing absolutely I would
this is an attacker in a country so what
happens is in our country's history
every elected official everyone that you
find out later there was a crime
committed I.E election fraud the real
winner gets put back in it's happened
every single election now that's never
happened at the presidential level right
that's the only difference so there is
precedence but also you you combine this
with this is an attack by China this was
a very very very uh it's a it's an act
of War basically as well
they've attacked us and the Democrats
warned us to this everybody they warned
us from my senator Amy Klobuchar to
Kamala Harris they all warned us about
this Cyber attack about going through
the machines and taking our country
without guns and they just happened to
use the Democrat Party so no matter who
you are we go back to it now the weren't
the the Supreme Court's going to get
this yeah uh we're going to give up
probably late August and now what they
do with it I'm not the Supreme Court but
they'll have some options they might put
you know pull it down and put Donald
Trump in right away because it's
evidence is non-subjective I see or or
because all the down tickets were
affected too many many down tickets
maybe the Supreme Court I'm just putting
it out there has a whole new election
wow well how could we have a new
election right
with these machines we can't but at the
Symposium on the 10th 11th and 12th of
August members live streamed on Frank
speech worldwide of course and worldwide
prankspeach.com we're going to live
stream at 72 hours straight we're going
to unveil a replacement for the machines
and Evelyn says well Mike are you going
to do that now you're going to show this
is just a money thing so you can make
money no we're giving the technology
away to all companies okay okay but so
to one I want to go one thing because
there's so much here my head is
literally spinning here Mike
um just to show how confident you are
that this reinstatement would happen
would you want to make a financial bet
with me on it because I just don't see
it and I want to prove to people just
how confident you are would you want to
put twenty five thousand dollars up
against me on it that by the end of
September Trump is reinstated one of my
addictions was gambling ah but not but I
will tell you this I put up five million
dollars a prize yeah cyber Symposium
five million dollars for anyone that's
there which is we've invited now we have
over 100 cyber cyber forensic experts
from around the country and a couple
from out of the out of this country what
what is that what does that mean a cyber
friend what's that credential a cyber
forensic they have cissp but it's more
than that these are these are guys that
protect our country a lot of them work
for the government that when you have a
Cyber attack these are experts that can
read these packet captures that can just
you know what actually happened the uh
you know it shows where the attack came
from the computer that was intruded how
many votes were flipped they're going to
read all this during the 72 hours we're
going to go through all 50 states and uh
a pack could capture everybody is like a
picture you can't change you can't all
that's true but Mike and this is so
important because I've looked I saw the
packet captures and I saw the the
numbers and I went in preparation for
the interview to be thorough I went to
some cyber experts on this what they
told me is that what you previewed I
don't remember if it was on Frank's
speech or on Newsmax or where it was a
couple weeks ago but you showed the
numbers scrolling they said that that's
absolutely meaningless that those are
called hex dumps and it's just a way to
look at computer memories
right we just put b-roll out there those
aren't the captures so we put b-roll
those are from the election those are
every single outlet including CNN I just
did a two and a half hour interview with
them about four days ago okay that's to
show you what this data if you're any
kind of a cyber guy you can decipher and
say well that was from the 2020 election
okay I should have told you that so what
you're saying is what you put up there
is the style of what you will be
unveiling at the Symposium but it is not
the actual data those were actual data
it was actual data that was actual data
100 actual data so if you talk to guys
that wasn't now that wasn't packet
capture that was data from the packet
captures yep that were captured so what
we're going to do at the Cyber Symposium
you're going to be able to go up to
imagine this we're going to have on
stage we're going to have a panel and
we're going to go just like election
night in the state of New Hampshire goes
to Donald Trump whoa this will be the
real election okay and on the to the
side of the stage we have a cyber cyber
Center any of these politicians or the
media if you got you're invited yourself
David if you want to come and then then
you can get your five million dollar
prize you can bring your own cyber guys
absolutely if you're beside the stage
you'll be able to punch in a state or a
county or the whole election if you
punch the whole election you got Donald
Trump winning 80 million to 68 million
but now you do this now listen we're
going to have these hundred cyber guys
that came from all over the country
these are none of them know each other
they were just they were they were you
know we invited and they they've called
in they've prevented them that they're
the they're good they're the best okay
so they're going to divide up into
groups like let's say eight to a group
and we're gonna give them a state here's
the state of Georgia here's the raw data
and they're gonna sit there and make
sure 100 percent that what we're what
I'm telling you is the truth they'll go
through it and they're going to go
through it I see they're gonna and then
we're gonna have them on the stage and
they're gonna have the people it's like
reading a language let's say let's say
this was all written in uh Chinese you'd
have to have people there that could
read the Chinese and say Yep this is
what it says now since it's
non-subjective every cyber guy will say
the exact same thing and when you're
watching that from home now when you're
watching that anybody's cyber guy or
anybody in the world that sees this will
be a hundred percent not 92 percent by
the time the Symposium is over everyone
Democrats Republicans liberals
conservatives are going to go well we
need to do something now this was an
attack by China this is real these
Heroes that captured this information
which is these packet captures our
government should have been doing this
because the Democrats weren't but yeah
but you don't they said oh they're not
none of the machines were online so why
would you it'd be like getting flood
insurance when you say hey there's not
going to be any water but they lied to
yeah they lied to the American people so
uh they're I'm I'm out of breath from
all of this information that you're
giving me Mike there's a couple other
things I want to get to and maybe on the
I know your time is short so maybe we
can keep these short I am not a
Christian so I may not be in a position
to understand this but if Donald Trump
was selected by God as you are certain
that he was why would God allow Joe
Biden to even become president and force
you to go through all of this why not
just put Trump in the white house again
well I believe I believe that that sub
that's part of this Divine Divine thing
that's going on because really people
don't look let me show tell you people
do not look for Hope unless things are
going bad huh and this that's why I
believe this will be the greatest
Revival for Jesus and we will be once
again one nation under God ever because
all these people including yourself are
going to see Miracles unfold here Mike
are you saying even even even a Jewish
guy like me will see Jesus
okay
what's that even a Jewish guy like me
Miracles you're going to see Miracles
unfold you're going to see Miracles
unfold you can believe whatever you want
but you're going to see things that you
thought were impossible okay happen and
you're saying you asked me why would God
why would God let this happen yeah well
if you don't people don't look for I'll
give an example
um I was in a you know I was in about
two years ago I was a guy and he said
and he goes Mike our nation has turned
his back on God people have turned his
back on him and he says we would need
people aren't looking for God and those
things bad happen and he said he goes if
something like the Great Depression I
said no no in the Great Depression they
had God they were just praying for food
and shelter I said we have something
better than that I said we have
addiction I said so this is when I set
up my lindo recovery Network done or I
said when you're an addiction you're
looking for hope you're looking out
there you need and it's about your soul
it's about salvation you're praying okay
but then Along Came the China virus the
pandemic and then came this election
ever everybody everybody is seeing what
is going on now I have Democrat friends
of mine and the liberal friends of mine
I talk to them they go wow I can't
believe this my
this my manifestation social I'm not
blaming the damn party I'm saying that
the China picked them and they use them
and you're going to see this at the
Symposium I see so you're gonna see
these when people say well coming
straightening out our country I'll give
an example to David then when Jimmy
Kimmel said to me in his attack he said
Mike would you do it if it was reversed
I said of course this isn't about Donald
Trump I said this is about saving our
country with with China and these
machines this is about saving not just
our country but the world all these
other countries are worried too they got
we are in an age where it's cyber
attacks this is yeah computers that can
take your country and and I said and you
know what happened after that they came
back the Washington Post and all these
Outlets came to Minnesota and asked my
friends and people from my past come on
would Mike really be sounding the alarm
if Donald Trump if they'd have picked
him trying to pick him every one of them
said yes David do you think they did a
story on that no every one of them
because you know what this is a about
our country this is about elections I
don't it doesn't matter who won or lost
it it's if when your vote didn't matter
and you're going to see that at the
Cyber Symposium nobody's voting matter
nobody's vote matter they use the 2010
census report that's why you have so
many rural counties where double the
people voted that even live in the
county and this was all these are done
on a total separate area with
mathematics yeah that we could not
approve this Mike there's this
incredible image of you in the aftermath
of the election leaving the White House
and a zoomed in picture sees you
carrying a paper that says martial law
on it who raised the topic of Martial
law in that meeting with Trump
well let me see now if you'd have done
your due diligence on that David I said
I was bringing him the evidence I got on
January 9th this cyber evidence that I
got brought to me on January 9th okay
that was four pages these other lawyers
had given me two pages to give to him I
had never even read it I didn't know
what was on it that got opened up it
never got talked about in the Oval
Office that's a very famous story there
I brought in the evidence this is why
I'm asking you yeah yeah but he said
bring this upstairs the lawyers brought
me upstairs now the sheets were over
they gave me the sheets back and I was
outside the back end and then they seen
that martial law in there
um it was never brought up in the Oval
Office it was okay and he didn't and the
sheets were given back and I brought
upstairs to his attorneys which shoot me
out of the White House okay that's why
I'm asking to get the story straight
from you two other real quick you know
what yes but that was so important you
know why yeah because no no media would
talk to Mike Lindell so from that point
on every single day I was attacked by
outs and trolls my retailers are gone on
my shopping channels they attacked Mike
Lindale my pillow Dominion sued over 200
people and or and use law fear in our
country to where last week I just had to
dump Fox shame on Fox news I've had to
use all the left-wing media every day
they have my direct number I get calls
from morning to night but you know what
they bashed me and they attacked me but
at least I get to talk about the truth
which is trying to attacked our country
and stole our election from the American
people last two things one do you have
voting machines in your possession
somewhere
two yes we do you do and how many of
them
I don't know that I don't know that the
if they I have no idea we're bringing
we're going to have that snowing we're
going to have at the Cyber Symposium
we're going to show you my collections
we're going to have site random cyber
people put in a soundproof room we're
going to capture the packets which are
in the routers of course that's why
Arizona Won't Give Up the routers strong
routers yeah
you know where did you get the voting
machines where did you get them
um there are no lawyers got them believe
me they were got legal you can buy them
on eBay there okay why don't you buy a
couple I don't have any use for them
quite frankly last thing my um Frank
speech it was billed as it will be the
new revolutionary social website when I
check it it's just like a video of you
talking what's going on with that now
that's Lindell TV that's correct you're
very incorrect if you go there there's
thousands of uh of uh these are all boys
the network part was built first so all
these people that have had their voices
suppressed yeah like your like your um I
don't know pick anyone that has been
kicked off a YouTuber Vimeo for talking
about machines or vaccines yeah or even
or even Jesus they've been kicked off of
there canceled out now they're over here
so we have a safe place where they know
they don't have their platform pulled
that's our Network part the social media
part is coming out probably in a month
or two oh okay and that that's the part
where people can go like the the Twitter
part right now for me the the media part
of so we would have a voice we have
millions of people on there now and so
when I talk the words getting out
instead of people like Fox that don't
let the word out right so now at least I
have the terrible media that bashes me
every day and I'm able to talk and on my
own platform and put out stuff that
doesn't get censored it's our First
Amendment right to free speech like Alan
dershowitz said well he's one of my
attorneys he said really you know Mike
this will be the most important case for
our first amendment right of free speech
in history because they only use law
fair one other time in 1798. well that's
where they use a lot there just suppress
so if you get you know it'll be amazing
if you know on your show if you can say
Dominion Dominion Dominion or smartmatic
smart manic you know Mike um I
appreciate your time so much are if if
this doesn't work out are you open to
the idea that maybe Joe Biden just won
or like are you even even theoretically
open to that David I put everything I
had on you're going to watch it too so I
would really like it if you came and
brought a cyber guy and tried to win the
five million dollar prize wow I know in
the beginning here you kind of mocked it
I'll bet you 25 000. I know you don't
believe it you don't know people don't
that was serious I would bet you 25. I
would invite to the Symposium uh and you
can send your own your own cyber guy win
the five million dollar prize you could
expand your audience
I'm traveling on that day one chance
there is 100 no chance that this didn't
happen because I'm showing evidence you
need to understand yeah it captures I
have it for the whole election I have it
in my possession it's like help me it's
like is this a phone yes it's a phone
that's why it's going to be a 9-0 vote
from the Supreme Court wow
asking him about anything that's
subjective this is the evidence it's
like it's like you and I taking a
picture in the 1970s where you couldn't
alter it right you know you can't alter
it you can't change it it shows
everything in detail because you have
the pack of captures it's like why in
Arizona did they want to give up the
routers because those show the packet
captures if you ask any cyber guy in the
world if you have a Cyber attack which
we have all the time on private
businesses uh the government everything
and we just had a Gaslight one these
cyber experts that I hire to validate
this evidence remember I've spent about
12 million 50 million dollars now of my
own money yeah validate all this
evidence so that I could sit here and
tell you I've already had the people the
best in the world look at it and they
said these are people that protect our
country and say this is 100 I said it's
not 99.9 they said no 100 I said well
when you when you have a Cyber attack or
breach
um is what's that you know do you need
more they said no if you have the packet
captions you you have it all Wow Mike
Lindell CEO and inventor of my pillow
Mike you've really said it all I we will
be watching we will be waiting for what
will happen over the next month or two I
really appreciate your time and telling
us your perspective today yeah if
everybody can get to I want the everyone
needs to watch this so you if you watch
frankspeach.com and you watch it during
any time during those 72 hours that's
all you're gonna need and you're gonna
be worried about I am about our country
are going to go David you'll be the
first one to call me I'll give you my
direct number you can go like what are
we going to do I will be watching Mike
appreciate it thank you thanks David